thank you all for coming and thank you
for the presentation so welcome
everybody to expressive and fast data
frames in Python with polars I tend to
talk a little bit too much and I do want
you to ask questions and have some
discussion so I will try to be quick
um so this is the outline of the talk
and I'm going to do a bit of an
introduction first of all and we're
going to talk very briefly about uh
pandas it's success but also some of its
limitations and then we're going to
mention very briefly what are the
Alternatives of or some of the
Alternatives that are available these
days and then we're going to see an
actual analysis uh carried out using
polars and
addressing conclusions so just to
reintroduce myself I'm a former
developer Advocate or at Rita docs I'm
currently working as a data scientist
Advocate at orchest which is a company
creating an open source pipeline
orchestrator
and we're going to see very briefly
during the demo and currently
looking into ways to accelerate the
solidarity economy through through
technology in case anyone is interested
and quitting Twitter so feel free to
join mastalon and follow me there I'm
cross posting in both places
am happy to connect with folks on GitHub
and Linkedin as well
so first of all the context of why are
we giving this talk so at orcas our
mission is to empower data scientists
and data Engineers by developing uh a
nice easy to use by Blaine orchestrator
and we identified a few use cases and we
were asking ourselves whether our users
were using the best tools available in
particular for data manipulation
um for for tablet data in particular so
we started focusing a little bit on a
data frame libraries and we wrote a
series of blog posts which evolved into
this talk today
so first of all pandas who has used
pandas already
so lots of people it's very widely known
and it totally reflects this plot that
we see here so for those of you that
don't know it this uh visualization
comes from a stack Overflow blog post
from 2017 that was describing or
analyzing how come python had
skyrocketed from like a normal language
in 2010 at the beginning of 2010 to the
most like the language with the largest
number of questions in stagger flow
right and if you break that down into a
different projects and tags you see that
a sure Django and flask has they have
had sort of a steady increase and I
would be super happy to see this plot
again with like Fast API
or some of the newer Frameworks but the
most important contributing factor to
this increase has been clearly the pi
data and the Scientific Python ecosystem
and in particular uh panels right so
it's everywhere many people use it and
it's been a super successful project
however it has some
um limitations so there's a blog post
called the 10 Things I Hate About pandas
written by the pandas creator that
analyzes a little bit what are some of
the bottlenecks that pandas has nowadays
I don't want to
extend myself too long because we happen
to have Jeff rebach and they need pandas
maintainer talking about the past
present and future of pandas so I highly
encourage you to attend his talk but
basically we can summarize this
bottlenecks in in
in two categories right so on one hand
most pandas operations don't take
advantage of multi-core this has been
evolving and there has been many people
um re-implementing or refactoring pandas
so that more and more operations take
advantage of multi-core but it's not uh
complete by any chance and even when
it's complete the fact that pandas is
eagerly evaluated and therefore when you
have a chain of operations imagine the
typical filtering and group buying and
aggregation and so forth each of these
objects
um have to be stored in Python memory
and therefore there is not much rune for
ahead of time query optimization right
and then on the other hand some of the
design decisions of pandas have affected
how the memory is managed and so forth
and for example the way missing data is
implemented in pandas and well it looked
good at the time but now there have been
people uh saying that it would have been
better to have like a mask array
approach so have uh basically a market
rate that says which are the valid
values right and then the values
themselves which needs twice as much
memory but it probably uses much more
the the CPU and several other things
like how strings are implemented and so
forth and but again I refer you to get
revac's talk and which I'm sure is going
to be super interesting and I would like
to clarify that I'm not throwing shade
at pandas because I love it it's a
wonderful project and it's not going
anywhere
but I would like to talk a little bit
about the Alternatives so if you are
like me six months ago you have probably
heard about many different projects that
are kind of like pandas but not exactly
or like they deviate in some ways so the
first thing I did was trying to map all
these Alternatives and inspired by the
famous Gardener uh infographics I
created the data frames Charming
quadrangle and released with I created
Commons license for all of you
and so we basically have this uh
landscape right on the top on the bottom
left corner we have pandas itself and
Rapids which is uh sort of a panda's
implementation on gpus right so it's
still for sort of small-ish data frames
or data frames that fit in Ram right but
some of the operations are much much
faster thanks to them leveraging the GPU
then on the top left corner we have a
dusk again we have Matthew brockling
talking about deploying desk later on in
this conference so if you're interested
check it out
and which take pandas to the distributed
world right so this allows us to use
essentially the same pandas apis but
with data frames that are much larger
than RAM and then you have all operates
like modding for example that try to
make the uh the process of switching to
a distributed uh setting much more easy
and the promise of modeling is that if
you change one line of code just the
import statement then
everything works
and on the top right corner I have this
category that you call recovering
hadoopers and because I don't really
have any experience with Apache spark so
I don't have anything meaningful to say
it's kind of weird because we have all
these uh projects right and trying to
um
accelerate python for large-scale data
processing but then wise park has been
there for a very long time and I think
there's just like an historical divide
that the communities are kind of
different and they overlap only a little
bit
but definitely a spark is induced by
lots of entities already and it's worth
checking out as well
and finally on the bottom right corner
we have new projects that don't
necessarily uh try to solve all your
needs for a huge data processing but
they deviate from the pandas API in some
interesting and very meaningful ways
so if you want to sorry if you want to
know a little bit more in depth about
Arrow itself or Vex I recommend you to
check out another talk that I gave
earlier this year that is recorded but
for the remainder of the presentation
we're going to focus on polars which for
me is one of the most interesting ones
so first a little bit of background what
is Arrow who knows Arrow here okay so
most
um of the people who is
aware of using Arrow at the moment
okay so not many people using it
consciously at least
so well arrow is this language
independent and memory format
and it has bindings for many different
languages right we have by arrow on
python which is based on the C plus
implementation but there's a rust
implementation as well that I'm going to
mention in a moment and many others so
it strives to be a cross-language
foundation and the interesting thing is
that by having this common in-memory
representation you can transfer data
between
languages very easily you can stream it
over a socket or something like that so
it's a really really powerful and I
I wouldn't say this is like a
replacement of a data frame library
because it's quite low level and but
it's no doubt becoming like a foundation
for the next generation of data frame
libraries
and then there's polars who has used
polars already before this talk
so there's a handful of people okay
so you're at the right place
um so polars
um describes itself as an in-memory
Lightning Fast data frame library for
rust and python so most of the business
logic is written in rust on top of the
rust Arrow implementation but it happens
to have a python layer too and both are
developed hand in hand the latest
version was released three days ago they
released a lot of versions very often
because the project is quite young and
so I highly recommend you to check the
change logs and the interesting thing
that we're going to see in the demo part
is that it has a lazy expression system
that sort of decouples the computation
from the data itself so you can express
what operations do you want to perform
on the columns and then apply those to a
particular data frame or whatever
and the fact that this is a lazy
expression allows spotters to optimize
the the query ahead of time and to try
to use as much
um as
the the resources of the computer as
much as possible
um
so that was a bit of an introduction to
uh to Bowlers and I want to uh comment
that if you're in this talk you will
probably enjoy some of the other talks
that are happening and this this couple
of days
so I as I said I have a recording about
um of an earlier version of this talk
where I talk about about iro and Vex and
you might have heard of duck TV which is
uh
SQL in memory SQL database for analytics
that is super interesting so you're like
a SQL person I recommend you to check
this blog post that I wrote
and that combines techdb and polars in
interesting ways and then there's uh a
tutorial on Friday about Fugue I don't
know if the few people are in the room
so make sure to check that out it's like
it's not a data frame Library per se but
it's a unified interface on top of spark
desk Ray
and then there's Ibis 2 and we have
again right after this talk in the other
room
uh called Iris expressive analytics in
Python at any scale so and make sure to
check all this out
okay so that was 15 minutes so I'm on
time and we have plenty of time for demo
so I'm going to verify that everything
works
there we go you can see the screen right
yes
Okay so
well I set up a tiny orcus project to
download a data set from kaggle that
contains uh I think it's a one percent
sample of all the stack Overflow
questions
and their tags as we're going to see and
my objective is to analyze this data set
and try to figure out what are the top
python questions and what questions do
you have python among the talk the tags
and all of that
so I'm going to make sure that
and all the steps are behaving correctly
which they should hopefully
so there we go we have the data and I'm
going to get in here
and to not spoil the talk I removed all
the outputs but I prepare the code to
not make it a super risky live demo
right because the light demo gods are
not always super kind to me
um
so there were two import polars is this
and import police as PL and as I said we
have
um a couple of CSV files and the tax one
is uh quite manageable but then the one
with the questions contains the body of
the question and the title and so forth
so it's uh quite big it's 1.8 gigabytes
and the Machine I'm doing this in it's
not particularly powerful and in fact if
I try to load the data set twice it's
going to completely crash the server and
I'm not going to try that so trust me on
that but this is just to prove that I
don't necessarily need a super powerful
machine to Crunch two gigabytes of data
so polars has a read csb function and
same name as the one we know and love
from pandas and what these returns is
polar's data frame objects that has
um convenience methods as well as in
Panda so it has a DOT head a method we
can use and this displays the first five
rows of the data set we can check that
the type of the DF
is polar's data frame
and the first thing we notice here is
that well this looks like a
annotation of a data frame that we would
expect
but
um
the the D types of each of the columns
here and we're going to see later on
when we manipulate this a little bit
more that the types that are available
importers are a little bit more
sophisticated at what we have right now
in pandas
so I'm also going to load the tags CSV
and as you can see I only have the ID of
the question and the tag itself so
naturally there can be more than one tag
per question so the ID might be repeated
and in total we have one million 1.2
million rows for the questions and 3.7
um
a million tags
okay so not too crazy also to keep the
the times the processing times
reasonable for this demo
um
but needs to be handled with care right
right and the estimated size in memory
for this sorry about the audio thing I
don't know why it's
um so the estimated size of this in
memory it's 1.8 gigabytes and right now
one silly thing that I really like about
polars is that you have this ASCII
representation of the data frame if you
use print which is super good for copy
pasting in in certain cases
and we'll have a described method that
gives us some information
and I can even do some simple processing
like checking which are the tags
globally the tags that are most uh
widely used right so value counts does
the same as pandas and then I'm starting
these by counts uh descending order and
displaying only the first one so I get
that JavaScript of course is the deck
that is most widely used then Java
c-sharp HP Android probably below here
it's
python right
so so far so good but then
um the interesting thing about polars as
I said is the expression system so we're
going to check that out
and the idea is that we have this
pl.call so a column function that
represents a column of a data frame we
have actually using the data frame so as
you can see here my data frame is DF but
in B cell I'm nowhere using that DF so
this is a generic representation of the
median of the score right and then I can
apply this to any data frame that I have
the way I do that is by using the select
method of the data frame itself so I
have the select method and then I pass
an expression
say this 15
is an expression and then I pass that to
select and it gives me the result right
so the median the mean score of all the
questions is 1.78
um
which is not unexpected right so most of
the questions have like one upvote
because nobody saw that and then some of
them have two and there's like a long
tail of scores
interestingly when I pass a list of
Expressions then all of these are going
to be computed in parallel so I have for
example the number of unique IDs and the
mean score again but also the maximum
length of all the titles and
by passing all these Expressions as a
list since they are all independent from
each other because I don't need to have
the length of the titles uh to compute
the number of unique IDs policy is going
to leverage all the
cores of the machine to make this as
fast as possible and I can't even do
something like this which is select all
The Columns of type utf-8 and compute
the lengths and then give me the maximum
of that so I have the length the maximum
length of all the columns that have
UDF 8
which is quite powerful
sorry I was a little bit too fast any
questions or comments so far yes
is it is polar is going to be more
sticky
so exactly this is what I'm going to
show in a moment
um but the idea is that uh as you say a
panda's object D type is quite generic
right most of the times it contains a
strain but it could be like a list of
numbers or virtually any other object
right so it's sometimes not really
useful but thanks to Arrow followers can
identify for example if a given column
is a list of strings for example or even
a structs because it has the notion of
of objects with different properties
within a given column as well so we have
we definitely have more granularity and
we're going to see an example of that in
a moment
thank you very much yes you do windowed
operations I think so yes I don't
remember that by heart but there's a
wonderful
okay this is worth uh checking there's a
wonderful polish book sort of a long in
user guide there's a window functions
and this one is quite useful it contains
lots of examples and walks you through
several things you might want to check
out and with colors
um
um and it has a reference guide as well
that contains like all the methods all
the functions and so forth this one is a
little bit difficult to navigate they
exist in different websites by the way
um
so yeah to answer your question yes we
have uh window functions windowed
aggregations and so forth
oops anything else
okay so let me continue
um
and this is when I'm going to start uh
showing some more interesting things
because I don't know if it hap if it
happens to you but in pandas especially
when you're reading like Json data for
example or doing some certain
aggregations and groupings when you end
up with a column of lists like a column
that contains lists of elements it's not
very uh handy to work with that in
pandas and you have to use like the dot
Str methods which is not very intuitive
either
um so it turns out that in Polish
there's a dedicated namespace for arrays
and lists of objects so you have the dot
Str methods as as I was showing here
like the length or something like that
but you also have dot r dot lens which
is something that you can use for a
column that happens to be a list and
but before I get there
[Music]
um
let's talk a little bit about lazy
evaluation here so
um the questions data frame is quite
large as you show and it turns out that
if I want to join the questions data
sets
ah that was it
so if I try to join the questions data
set with the tags to know what tags
correspond to each question right and
I'm going to run out of ram I'm not
going to try it because it's going to
ruin my presentation forever but
um you can try this at home if you have
some spare time
and so what would be the way to do this
right and the answer is that by default
polish has uh this eager evaluation so
every intermediate step is going to
return a Polish object but it also has a
lazy evaluation mode
now it's quite easy to use so after a
data frame that it's already in memory
then you put this dot lazy method and
all the operations that you do after
that are going to become lazy so they're
not being evaluated just yet and for
example in this case I'm joining with
also a lazy version of the tags data
frame on the column ID and I'm doing a
semi-joint which is a magical thing that
I didn't see in pandas and that does
like an inner join but discard some
extra columns I still don't understand
don't fully understand how it works but
it feels great and
and I'm filtering only uh those rows
where the lowercase tag contains the
word python okay so I'm keeping only
these questions sorting by ID ascending
and to go from a lazy chain of
operations to the actual data frame that
you call Dot collect at the end which is
quite similar to how one would do things
in like dusk or something like that and
you end up with this so I do have
um
the questions here
yes and I'm since I'm doing a semi-joint
the tag column doesn't actually appear
here
but I'm filtering and the questions that
have that tag over there and this I left
a note to myself to restart the kernel
here because otherwise
I will run out of memory so I'm
restarting here and I'm going to
um instead of reading the whole
questions data frame to memory I'm going
to do something else so instead of doing
a read CSV and then a DOT lazy right
that allows me to write a lazy chain of
operations but on a data frame that
already exists in memory I'm going to do
something else and I'm going to use scan
CSV so a scan CSV does not read the
whole data frame in memory but it kind
of points to it and then when you do and
it returns a lazy data frame instead of
uh in memory data frame right so it's
better than calling read CSV dot lazy
because I'm not actually reading that
completely
and I'm essentially doing the same
operations
um
but storing the chain of operations in a
separate variable and the cool thing
about this separate variable is that you
can also visualize when this is done
after a few seconds you can also
visualize how polars is optimizing this
chain of operations internally so you
end up with
plots like this I'm not sure why
and I don't know the Polish authors
wrote all these mathematical symbols at
the beginning I guess it means like
number of partitions or something like
that I haven't
done a lot of research on that but at
least we see that we're joining to data
frames and we're filtering then sorting
and so forth so if our chain of
operations becomes too complex then
polars hopefully will be able to merge
some of those operations and optimize
them somehow
and what time is it okay so we have
10 minutes left
um so
now to the original question that I
asked myself right so what are the top
uh python questions
well it turns out that
um I have more tags than questions right
so I had to join this somehow and what
I'm going to do is to turn each of the
rows of the tags into a single row per
question where I have the list of tags
like this and the way I'm doing that is
by using this
um you'll call Tag dot list
okay so I'm grouping by ID and then each
ID group and turning the tags into an
actual list so rather than aggregating I
am like concatenating all these tags to
come up with a tag list column and as I
was saying a few minutes ago you see the
D type of that is list of strings so
boilers knows that this is not just an
object it's a list of strings and it has
its own set of operations
um
and after I have the list of tags and I
was kind of amazed that I could do this
so essentially I have this dot r dot
eval that takes an expression that I'm
passing and then it's evaluating that
for each of the elements of the list for
each of the rows right so for every
element I'm asking whether the lowercase
version of that contains python and
finally if any of those is true
basically so I'm saying okay for every
row tell me which ones contain the
contain a tag that contains the
substring python right because there
could be Python 3 or python Dash
something something so it's not enough
to check for equality
and it turns out that it works okay so
all of these don't have python in the
list of tags but then python bash
multiline does have it and so forth then
I share this with Richie the author of
Polaris in the Discord server and told
me no but that's too complex you can do
that in two lines and without using the
tax list intermediate intermediate thing
I just left the other code because I
know it just looks beautiful that you
can do that but yes you can have the tag
list and you can say okay for every tag
and let me know if it contains the
substring python and then turn that into
another column right
with the
um
with the group by and aggregation we
were using before
um
and I think this is almost the end yes
so now what I'm doing is repeating again
the scan CSV I'm joining with the tag
list that I have uh that tells me
whether a question contains a tag that
contains the word python filtering that
and then sorting them by score and
limiting the first a thousand of them so
at the very end when this is done
I will be able to select
um like all the columns except the body
like I'm doing here and then displaying
the most highly voted python questions
let's keep this a few more seconds
hoping that the machine doesn't die
yes there we go so
we have all the questions containing
python here and I'm going to increase
the width over here a little bit config
set
so how do I randomly select an item from
a list that happens to be the most
highly voted python question
manually raising throwing an exception
in Python these are right quite all
right like 2008 2010 and makes total
sense right like all the questions have
more upvotes and but yeah that's it so
happy that nothing broke and uh
is there any follow-up questions before
I move to the conclusions yes
and to not run out of memory basically
because when like reading the whole
questions data frame in memory is
possible like I have slightly more than
two gigabytes of RAM but then when
you're going to join that with something
else it was happening to me that it was
crashing so I'm using that to basically
go beyond what the ram of my machine
would allow
yes and one follow-up to that before it
turns out
that and one month ago Richie
implemented what he called streaming
support and managed to turn like 80
gigabytes of CSV uh on a machine with 16
gigabytes of RAM which is impressive I
didn't want to test that
um because I think that would be too
dangerous for a live demo but apparently
it worked and I'm looking forward to use
it
yes
what about desk
um
maybe it's closer than you think so this
is a screenshot that I took today so
nine days ago today Matthew Rocklin in
an issue that someone opened asking what
about desk said well we have a prototype
like dusk on top of polars and basically
he's sourcing feedback from the
community to understand what are the use
cases and so forth so
um the key Point here is that polars
started as uh in-memory data frame
Library very similar to pandas right now
it has gone a little bit beyond that so
we can do out of core computation and
therefore load data frames that are
larger than Ram but to take this to a
huge distributed setting
and you will probably need some or
chestration and things like that and I
would say that dusk plus polars is going
to be
the answer that we're looking for
hope that answers the question
kind of okay
yes
focusing on
so a random sample but what do you mean
a random sample to get the same results
some of the Rose
the rose for him
I guess for like some aggregate
statistics like the median score
something like that would be perfectly
fine to sample in a smart way though I'm
not aesthetician so I would probably do
it wrong but uh
would be okay to sample but in this case
since I'm trying to get the most highly
voted questions I guess I had to use the
whole data frame anyway
and unless I'm missing something so
um
for the use cases where you actually
need like all the data or something like
that resorting to an alternate days a
little bit faster and could go a long
way
yes
when you're sure that like the data
frames you're using are small for
example I was doing a small analysis at
home of some data that I scrapped from
my website and it was a bunch of Pros I
don't know hundreds of rows or something
like that and I didn't bother doing the
dot lazy dot collects
um because it's also slightly faster and
probably easier to debug
as well like I expect the errors to be
less cryptic probably
um but yeah apart from that when you
know that the data set is going to be
huge probably I would use the lazy
interface every time
or I don't know where they are but like
the first three commands are successful
and then the fourth one it failed
so
if you're using the lazy evaluation I
don't know how would that work if you're
using the eagle one then probably you
can sort of kind of bisect with your
your problems are coming right
and there's also a way to teleporters to
not to optimize the query planning just
in case that happens to be some sort of
bottleneck or or mistake in the
optimization so there's a couple of
scape hatches but I haven't yet used
this in in production for like a right
would work if you did
it right right
yes so
um
I don't remember there's like a direct
SQL interface but for example you can
connect to several databases
and using this connector X Library
or psycho pd2 but if you want to run SQL
on
um a file I definitely recommend you to
check the TV
that's exactly what you're looking for
I think I think I run out of time
already so
real quick and what about the index
there's no index anywhere James Powell
is upset and I can understand so
does it matter I'm not sure but it's
worth discussing anyway
and yeah pandas is okay but followers
rocks and thank you very much and happy
to connect as I said thank you everybody
and see you around